[Musica]
[Applauso]
mi chiamo diva tomei e stasera vorrei
parlarvi di un percorso di conoscenza
che ho iniziato alla nasa
quando facevo parte di un corso di studi
chiamato singolari university in questa
università studenti di imprenditori
venivano messi insieme e di fronte ad
una ad un quesito in questo fondamentale
che era come fare ad aiutare oltre un
miliardo di persone a migliorare la
qualità della propria vita attraverso la
tecnologia
naturalmente non ho la risposta però
loro ci hanno aiutato molto dandoci
un'infarinatura generale su tutti i temi
di tecnologia più avanzati più rilevanti
poi però alla fine ci hanno chiesto di
sceglierne uno
stasera io vi parlo di quello
approfondimento questa è l'immagine
della terra molto importante molto
particolare è stata fatta nel 1972 dalla
dall'equipaggio della missione apollo 17
questo equipaggio nel vedere questa
terra la chiamata la biglia blu blu
morbo questa è una foto molto speciale
della terra non perché era una foto
della terra vista per la prima volta
dallo spazio
ma perché è la foto della terra vista
completamente illuminata dal sole per la
prima volta dallo spazio è stato un
momento molto importante nella storia
dell'uomo perché è stata la prima volta
che l'uomo ha potuto vedere da un punto
di vista esterno la terra e riconoscere
nella terra in questo pianeta
la propria casa nell'universo come ogni
casa che si rispetti è molto importante
conoscerne la storia conoscere gli
equilibri nel caso del nostro pianeta
che la tengono tuttora in vita
iniziamo già localizzando c quindi
questo viaggio tutti sappiamo che la
terra fa parte di un sistema solare
perché c'è stato
da piccole un sistema solare che è
scomposto da otto pianeti che girano
orbitano intorno al sole la stella
centrale
questo sistema solare si trova
all'interno della via lattea che è la
nostra galassia
naturalmente noi ancora non possediamo
la tecnologia che ci permette di uscire
fuori da questa galassia e vederla come
abbiamo fatto per la terra da un punto
di vista esterno perché questo
richiederebbe un viaggio di circa 200
milioni di anni luce
ancora no ma quello che abbiamo potuto
fare è stato mandare in orbita un
satellite molto speciale un telescopio
spaziale che ha come caratteristica
principale quella di orbitare la terra e
di non puntare verso la terra ma puntare
verso lo spazio profondo
naturalmente a differenza dei telescopi
terrestri alla stragrande illustra
grande vantaggio che non deve vedere
attraverso l'atmosfera che è un ostacolo
importantissima per i telescopi
terrestri quindi immaginatevi questo
hubble che nel 1990 viene mandato in
orbita e comincia a guardare infisso
intensamente lo spazio profondo
tante immagini ci ha restituito questo
telescopio spaziale è la più importante
perché quella più recente è quella del
2019 che si chiama la hubble agassi
field lagasi perché rappresenta in un
certo senso i confini della nostra
conoscenza riguardo dell'universo in cui
viviamo in questa immagine vediamo una
fettina immaginate piccolissima di
spazio perché è quasi una traiettoria
lineare quella che sta osservando
ci sono voluti oltre 265 giorni
cumulativi di esposizione per vedere
così in profondità e quello che state
guardando è un viaggio nel tempo perché
perché ci sono galassie in questa
immagine che sono retrodatate a 12
miliardi di anni fa
12 miliardi di anni fa per darvi un
contesto temporale è all'incirca quando
c'è stato il big bang
che risale al 13.7 miliardi di anni fa
quindi alcune di queste galassie sono le
prime classi che sono mai esistite
nell'universo l'interazione tra queste
galassie iniziali poi ha formato le
galassie moderne come andromeda che è
distante da noi due miliardi e mezzo di
anni luce
la ball non sarà a lungo da solo in
questi anni alla nasa stanno costruendo
vedete in questa immagine le fasi finali
di assemblaggio del james webb space
telescope che lancerà se non ritarda
ancora a marzo del 2000 21 e andrà in
aiuto alla ball con una tecnologia molto
più imponente questi specchi che vedete
in totale misurano a 6 metri e mezzo di
larghezza contro circa i due e mezzo
della ball quindi immaginate che cosa
potrà vedere questo telescopio non solo
per questo per questo motivo ma anche
perché non orbiterà intorno alla terra
ma intorno al sole
quindi era noi ci aspettiamo dice con la
comunità scientifica si aspetta delle
immagini molto rivelatorie torniamo però
ad esplorare il nostro pianeta
quando il sistema solare la terra si
sono formati 4 miliardi e mezzo di anni
fa il sole non era così come lo vediamo
oggi il sole è una nana gialla
c'è una stella relativamente giovani e
da con tutte le nane gialle la
caratteristica di aumentare la propria
luminosità nel tempo questo è dovuto ad
un fenomeno di forte forza
gravitazionale che tende a farlo con
l'assale collassare a cui che è tipica
di queste masse così imponenti come
quella del sole a cui il sole deve
contrastare una fusione nucleare è
sempre più grande questa fusione
nucleare è sempre più grande e genera un
calore sempre più grande però quando il
sistema solare è nato il sole aveva
circa il 70 per cento della luminosità
attuale è sorta spontanea una domanda
all'interno della comunità scientifica
come ha fatto la terra ad adattarsi nel
tempo a questo cambiamento
se volete un po radicale rispetto
le condizioni che sulla terra hanno
ospitato per tre miliardi e mezzo di
anni la vita che ha bisogno di acqua
liquida quindi come ha fatto la terra da
adattarsi a mantenere un ambiente
ospitabile stabile il clima vivibile e
un'atmosfera una composizione
dell'atmosfera abitabile
la risposta c'è stata attraverso un
intuizione nella seconda metà del 1900
che era supplente che è stata la
seguente la componente di vita sul
pianeta è in equilibrio dinamico con
l'ambiente planetario cioè pensate tutto
quello che non evita rocce sedimenti
montagne fiumi oceani questo equilibrio
dinamico fa sì che la terra sia un
pianeta resiliente cioè sempre in grado
una volta perturbato di tornare indietro
al suo punto di equilibrio centrale non
vi spaventate lo so che tardi per
spiegarvi il principio della cibernetica
ma è semplicissimo e per capire ancora
meglio la regolazione che è alla base
della diciamo di questo equilibrio
dinamico dobbiamo capire un principio
base della cibernetica che si suddivide
in due tipi di regolazioni quella
positiva e quella negativa la positiva è
una regolazione che propaga un segnale
all'interno del sistema cosa vuol dire
se voi vedete qui la xe la ypsilon causa
ed effetto
queste sono messe in relazione nella
regolazione positiva in questo modo
all'aumentare dx aumenta y questo
aumentare di y
aumenta nuovamente hicks questo
ulteriore aumento aumenta ancora di più
y e così via in un sistema ciclico che
amplifica il segnale iniziale nella
stessa direzione
il feedback negativo invece è al
contrario all'aumentare dx aumenta y
ma questo mentre di y diminuisce hicks
quindi questa perturbazione iniziale è
immediatamente contrastata da un ritorno
all'equilibrio la regolazione negativa
quindi è la base del mantenimento dello
status quo
la terra quindi è un sistema che
a un insieme di questi cicli positivi e
negativi che al netto
evidentemente per nostra esperienza in
diretta sappiamo che il ciclo il
feedback la regolazione negativa deve
avere la meglio perché noi sappiamo la
terra un sistema resiliente quindi che
torna indietro che mantiene lo status
quo
però abbiamo appena visto che esiste
anche il feedback positivo quindi che
cosa ci deve far a cosa ci deve far
riflettere questo al fatto che se
dovesse mai esserci se l'attività umana
ad esempio dovesse mai perturbare il
sistema in un modo sufficientemente
grande da instaurare un feedback
positivo grande questo questa
propagazione di questo segnale potrebbe
arrivare a spostare l'equilibrio invece
di tornare indietro al punto di
equilibrio potrebbe spostare potrebbe
spostare questo equilibrio il ri
caratterizzare il pianeta in modi a noi
oggi sconosciuti ad esempio una terra
completamente congelata o una terra
completamente liquida un esempio che
abbiamo probabilmente tutti noi vissuto
è stata l'emergenza climatica legata al
buco nell'ozono
negli anni 80 90 questo è un perfetto
esempio di come l'attività umana a ciò è
arrivata molto vicino a spostare
l'equilibrio del pianeta
voi dovete pensare che lo strato
dell'ozono è il nostro scudo protettivo
perché ci ripara dai raggi ultravioletti
del sole gli uv al più vivi e gli obici
50 per cento degli uv ha però perché gli
altri 50 sono utili però quella prima
meta anche se l'ozono viene a viene meno
quindi c'è un assottigliamento eccessivo
dello strato di ozono
la superficie terrestre verrebbe
completamente sterilizzata quindi è
molto importante e in natura esiste un
equilibrio dinamico quello che abbiamo
visto precedentemente che fa sì che la
velocità di formazione di questo strato
è uguale alla velocità b
distruzione di questo strato in modo che
lo strato rimane dello stesso spessore
nel 1971 però la comunità scientifica ha
rilevato per la prima volta un accumulo
di cfc clorofluorocarburi nell'atmosfera
questi sono dei gas che vengono emessi
dalla nostra industria e nei processi di
refrigerazione
che cosa è successo che i modelli di
chimica atmosferica avevano predetto una
velocità molto più lenta di quella che
poi è stata e la strumentazione non è
stata in grado di rilevare un
assottigliamento che stava accadendo
gradualmente lo accantonava come errore
del sistema e non ce ne parlava nel 1985
improvvisamente noi vediamo questa
immagine questa a e questo è a tutti gli
effetti un buco in buco nello strato
dell'ozono
quindi la comunità scientifica entra in
grande shock e che cosa accade
il protocollo di montreal del 1987
sottoscritto da 59 paesi diversi e oggi
ratificata da 197 fa in modo che
globalmente queste missioni debbano
essere ridotte dal 2012 il buco comincia
a rimpicciolirsi e oggi è molto più
piccolo di com'era nel 1985
quindi ci siamo arrivati vicini ma non
siamo arrivati a perturbare il sistema
in modo da di caratterizzarlo però
questo è un esempio molto importante che
ci deve far riflettere
negli ultimi 180 anni della nostra
storia
noi abbiamo continuato a ragionare in
modo lineare mentre lo stato attuale
delle cose ci richiede di ragionare in
un modo circolare perché noi continuiamo
a ragionare in modo lineare perché
l'abbiamo fatto per 10.000 anni da
quando per la prima volta l'uomo
addomestica la natura con l'agricoltura
ma in quel momento
questo concetto del aver bisogno di una
risorsa e di procurarsela quindi questo
concetto molto semplice molto lineare
andava bene era sufficiente
oggi questo non è più vero perché la
popolazione globale sta
stando in numero e anche le sue esigenze
stanno aumentando quindi necessariamente
a un'esigenza non può corrispondere allo
sfruttamento di una risorsa deve
corrispondere anche la reintroduzione di
quella risorsa nel sistema e non
possiamo nemmeno più agire in modo
inconsapevole perché oggi abbiamo
strumentazione che fa monitoraggio
capillare del territorio su scala
globale
ogni giorno e parlo ovviamente di
satelliti di ultima generazione
metereologici di osservazione della
terra che ci danno una quantità di dati
infinita su come il sistema terra si
autoregola questi dati non posso non
essere presi sul serio perché ci
permetteranno di tarare il nostro
comportamento
la nostra produttività come società in
modo da evitare di arrivare a spostare
l'equilibrio e di caratterizzare il
sistema e sta ovviamente a tutti noi a
informarci sempre di più su questi temi
perché perché una conoscenza popolare
grande porta ad una società più
responsabile più consapevole e una
società più consapevole e più
responsabile ha una coscienza collettiva
molto forte e questo ci permetterà da
oggi nel futuro di fare le scelte giuste
questi sono scusate alcuni degli account
che io utilizzo per rimanere sempre
aggiornata e spero che da oggi in poi vi
possiate usare anche voi grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]